if you had to have a different type of
ethnicity that's clearly not in your
bloodstream what would you want to do
Nigeria 100 Nigeria how come I don't
know I just feel like all the Nigerian
people I mean are really smart and
really athletic oh and I need some of
that is that why do you why was that
weird you guys all got quiet why is that
weird I don't know that you knew that
many nightmare beside the UFC fighters I
think there's definitely a weirdness
I said it too quick is that where all
the runners come from I'd want to be
Antarctic the [ __ ] is that Antarctica
dude people from Antarctica aren't they
just Penguins that's just Penguins
there's no humans like native people
researchers antarcticans people lived in
North Pole what are you guys talking
about Santa Santa no not polish North
Poland North polish an Antarctic kid is
a fictional or hypothetical holy [ __ ] I
made that up wholesale
nah dude no way it says fictional or
hypothetical I want to be hypothetical
yeah and Arctica am I saying that right
Antarctica now it sounds weird when I
say it